heute gibt's bei uns ein schnelles
Mittagessen weil wir eben recht wenig
Zeit haben dafür verwende ich einfach
alles an Gemüse was wir noch im
Kühlschrank übrig haben erhitze das
Olivenöl in einem großen Bräter das
Gemüse wird dann einfach schön fein
geschnitten ich habe jetzt hier etwas
Zwiebeln und
Lauch dann kommen noch Champignons mitit
dazu und eine rote Paprika alles schön
anbraten bis die Röstaromen entstehen
und dann kommen als Sättigungsbeilage
Maultaschen dazu die sind jetzt bei uns
heute aus dem Tief Fach bzw Kühlfach und
da könnt ihr stattdessen auch gnoki z.B
nehmen oder Schupfnudeln bisschen
gemüsebrühpaste und Wasser dazu und
fertig das ganze nur noch einkochen als
Beilage gibt's unseren leckeren
gurkenschmand dafür hobeln wir ein paar
Gurken verrühren den mit Schmand mit
Gewürzen Salz und Pfeffer und etwas Dill
natürlich mit rein zur maultaschenpfanne
kommt jetzt noch etwas frischer
babyspinat der wird nur kurz
untergerührt und schon ist das Gericht
fertig guten appeet